it's a question my wife asks me almost
every single day it seems as when is
Game of Thrones coming back and it
returns for season seven this Sunday at
9:00 Eastern on HBO and the man who
plays the king of the North Jon Snow Kit
Harington here on the Rich Eisen show
thank you for coming baby back in that
you bet so what has this experience been
like for you to play Jon Snow on a an
internationally-renowned show like Game
of Thrones I mean you can't predict
being a part of something like this when
I thought when I got this show I was you
know pretty much fresh out of drama
scores 22 years old and and then it's
it's completely it's you know it's been
the whole of my 20s and it's been a
major part of my life it's been
incredible did you read the books when
you first got the gig essentially said
yeah yeah I read the books I kinda I got
I got the gig then I knew the books
existed so I read the books so I knew it
was kinda had potential to be this
amazing series this it's very complex
interesting fantasy but yeah no one else
seemed to read the books I think I was
definitely wanted to hold on a second
really
are you seriously yeah other than other
actors and actresses on Game of Thrones
didn't sit down and do any reading no no
well no I'm shopping them all in now I
don't know maybe they maybe some of them
did but I think I was one of the only
ones who kind of maybe went when that
for to read those tombs and so who is
Jon Snow do you think who we think yeah
like in what sense is it how about this
is is he as good as he seems to be deep
down deep down is a good dude that we
should all be rooting for I think yeah I
don't know you know I only I know his
bad sides and I'm never going to tell
you what they are is the scenes you
never see the scenes that ways a
horrible insipid character no but he is
he's just he's a good man he's like the
is pretty much one of the only good guys
in the story and that's er that's that's
a nice thing to play you know you
there's a lot of other people like who
only plays where
Boulton it just gets abuse in the street
or Jack Gleeson he who played Joffrey
there's so much abuse in the street
because people can't detach them from
the character mm-hmm
whereas like I get a lot of love because
a lot of people seem to kind of root for
John that is true yeah for sure
yeah I mean I there's a photograph my
wife I took of my wife right after the
episode where you died spoiler alert
yeah and her hand is over her mouth she
can't handle the truth of what's
happened and we honestly sat in quiet
for five minutes
full solid five minute dead quiet
yeah did you know at the time when that
happened that you would be coming back
to life or did you have a period where
you did not know as an actor that Jon
Snow had passed I had a two-week period
where I was pretty silent for those two
weeks after reading the script I didn't
know I didn't know what was going to
happen and know whether I was gonna I
was out of a job
you know I pretty much convinced myself
I was out at the job I was like oh this
was a good series you know this is a lot
of fun you got some good money it was
good wow this is good run yeah yeah now
you make do other things and then when
they told me that I was I was coming
back I couldn't say it kind of when you
lie to yourself and you're like oh I'll
be fine I'll be fine and then you get
the news and you go yes thank you so I
knew actually deep down I didn't want to
leave the show but I'm sure people were
close to you were coming up to you
asking you the same question
did you have to keep that under wraps
yeah I kind of did I did I did for a
little while and then you can't like it
effects too much of your life to go it's
like one of your best friends comes up
and says you brought you out of a job
now like you're not in Thrones anymore
what's going on and you can't just light
them and go yeah so what are you can do
next year you want go on holiday well I
had this other thing what's the other
thing well I don't know I can't you
can't string those lies along for too
long and eventually you have to tell
people but it is weird your whole life
being a cliffhanger I didn't like that
off bit of that season because it's
strange that you feel like part of your
life is a cliffhanger as well
as this fictional characters in the show
so you did not when did you learn how
you were going to come back to life when
you got the first script did you reach
out to the producers or writers I didn't
know how I was came back to life I just
knew that they said don't cut your hair
you know you what they said yeah don't
change anything don't go do anything
drastic we don't want to tell you this
because we wanted you to be worried but
now we have to tell you so why would
they want you to be worried their
sadistic the showrunners are sadistic if
you not noticed that yet is so horrible
they're horrible people they like
causing pain so yeah they they they you
know they they did tell me and I'm safe
keeps a kid Harrington the actor from
Game of Thrones the man who plays Jon
Snow the current king of the north here
on the Rich Eisen show so you have in a
recent interview with Entertainment
Weekly said Sansa and John Snell have
tension and that a power struggle is
coming can you put any more meat on
those bones for fans of the show me and
Sophie how in real life feel very much
like brother and sister we squabble a
lot like we get we get at each other
it's fun mm-hmm so we kind of bring that
yeah I think they kind of like thing
about Thrones is they sort of use what
you will have what what us as actors are
kind of using in real life how we how we
kind of get on and real life and then
they embellish that into the series is
that so yeah it's quite it's quite
anything like doing things what examples
from the past have have that you can lay
out here is something that they've done
personnel Isis commented on how our
short I am in life so they keep putting
that into Jon Snow you know being small
having a tiny pecker you know stuff like
this it's just they just they just want
to rip the piss out of it
why does that they are really sadistic
yeah yeah I got a neighborhood created
Ramsay Bolton in the red wedding and
think while the red wedding was in the
books but Ramsay Bolton in the scene
with the dogs and yeah defne of the dumb
wife they're not nice people I promise
you though they're really not nice so
what can you tell us about this CR you
first of all are you done shooting are
you Finn
is it all in the wind yeah we finished
season seven so that's in the can clan
tele from season 8 I'm still in a lot of
peril okay so you have to wait and see
but um yeah we've finished that it's
it's it's an amazing season it's it's
going to be a different type of epic we
did seven episodes instead of ten so we
could put so much more of resources into
into those seven episodes and that's a
great battle sequences this and that we
push CGI to the new limits this year so
it's going to be to be very kids to me
sighs do you have any idea if you're
going to be involved in any anything
that happens after Game of Thrones is
over there's so much conversation about
other shows spin-offs if you will of
Game of Thrones do you know if you're
going to be involved in anything of that
nature it's not sure you could do it
Jon's nice enough it might just be too
morbid see why would that be I mean if
you're not going to die I mean you're
going to come back right you're sort of
I know you're liable in that respect I
think we're I think we're we're done the
current class is sort of done with with
Game of Thrones once it's done but
there's so much scope for spin-offs I'm
sure they'll do other things in that
world and I hope they do such a rich
world and well what's your favorite fan
theory that you've heard my favorite if
somebody's come up to you and came up
with a a theory about Jon Snow or
anything about Game of Thrones that a
three or four a loop there was one there
was a weird one where it almost doesn't
make sense but they kind of this but
this guy came at me and said that you
liked that he thought that it would all
end and it would plan out and it all
been one of like my it'd been a dream
ghosts had been having a dream that make
sense that goes to my direwolf had
dreamt it all somehow so Game of Thrones
and that was that was his theory and he
was dead serious about it I want that
too please never become a screenwriter
getting worse ending can you imagine if
it ended like that that it ends and it
just zooms in on yeah that's the worst
ending like they wake up and it's a
dream but that's this it's a dog dream
no me well I think the worst
would be is that it would not be ghost a
direwolf but it would be ghost just a
regular dog in a house in a house
someone's in your and you're the one
who's coming I'm hi honey I'm home and
you just flipped ghosts a snack yeah and
it has nothing to do with Westeros yeah
nothing to do with Kingdom okay any
dream that I mean actually are now I'm
talking about it that's that would be
you really wanted to piss off everyone I
been watching for the whole time spin
off that's all understand yeah how about
that yeah the ghost and Jon Snow and
anybody in it actually we find out that
when it's all said and done you did know
nothing yeah yeah yeah when it all come
and come and gone Kit Harington is here
we're going to take a 60-second break
we'll come back we'll talk a little bit
of sport did I use that problem with you
yes we say sports split no sports or
sports in the UK it is yeah I just tried
to sound smarter okay kid Harrington is
here from Game of Thrones we're back
with more than 60 seconds welcome back
to the Rich Eisen show another segment
with Kit Harington a game of Thrones
again premiers Season seven this Sunday
at 9:00 Eastern Time on HBO you are a
fan of man you correct and the lifelong
lunch as you know it why is that is that
from your neck of the woods is just a
team that you grew up loving or how did
you get involved with love of Manchester
United I grew up in London and then
moved to a place called Wooster I didn't
even go to Manchester till I was about
11 years old I'm what they call a true
red I've never I never went to the based
in grew up in it but I grew up next to a
an Irish family who and there's a big
contingency of Manchester United fans in
Ireland my parents weren't really into
football or sport but me and my brother
idolized one of one of the sons in this
family one of the one of the one of the
guys he's building us and I kind of
picked the team because he support them
so Manchester United is your team and so
Wayne Rooney after 13 years yeah good
good service heating sails into the club
no question now he goes back to again
I'm going to try and use the phrase
boyhood team because that's not a phrase
that we use in the United States his boy
a team Everton yeah where he broke
it's a 16 year old and what do you make
of of that maneuver by way I'm really
unhappy about it actually I'm I kind of
think it's the right choice on his part
he has a young family obviously is one
uproot them I think he's I think that
those Everton fans that were so furious
with him for leaving that Club and
coming to United I don't think you know
he wanted to go and play for one of the
biggest clubs in the world he came to
our club he thought he was a greatest
ever goalscorer he's been amazing for us
and now he's going back to the team he
supported since he was a boy that when
he joined first and I think that's a
lovely full circle you know I think
that's a great great thing that he's
doing I kind of salute him for it and I
wish him luck Everton I mean that's
that's an amazingly well are there
Manchester United fans who think
differently from that who think he's
he's their budget from going back to his
roots see no I don't think so
I think he'd be very the very sour
person if you if you proposed him that
and I think I hope the Everton fans
welcome welcoming back with open arms as
well because I think he's still got you
know he's a different player now he's
lost his pace he's lost his legs a bit
but he's still ER he's got incredible
incredible brain on him credible
footballing brain and I think and his
instinct still that I think he's still
got a couple of really good years in him
for Everton so I hope that they welcome
him back I'm sure they will did you ever
try your hand at football I was if I was
a rugby player when I was young rugby
yeah I was a scrum half in rug bed that
means nothing to use it well I'm trying
to actually you just I tried not to
Balai my thorough ignorant yeah but you
did see I feel that facial a lose a
glazed look not I mean I'm hanging on
your every word cure yeah there's no
question about that but what do you what
what what do you mean by by rugby
no not rugby what was the phrase that
you used a scrum off okay let's come
after the little guy okay he's the
smallest guy in the rest beating just
yapping scrappy yeah he's hard to catch
and he takes a ball out of the scrum
half
he's a balcony and he gets out to the
back hmm but at the back line you might
say so you'd you realized early on that
perhaps acting was the better way for
you to go is that we were saying I
remember the tackle that did it yeah
what was that I you know I was a row
rugby I was playing quite a high level
but there's something that happens to
young men when they go from being like
16 17 years old to suddenly I was
playing 18 years old and you know when
young men go from being young men to men
and I remember that I got hit with a
tackle I was in the drama Society same
time as being the rugby team and I kind
of I thought I got a I got to protect
this you know the moneymaker I've got
I'm gonna protect the moneymaker
one more hit like that to my face and
that you know I can kiss acting goodbye
were you the only hybrid at the time
being drama and rugby we're the only guy
was I think I was glowing both I was
trying to pick the two things I kept I
could to get the most girls were like
being a like a jock yeah and also doing
acting loads of being the artistic kind
of mysterious one mm-hmm
it was all motivated by chasing skirt
well kid I think it's worked out for you
there's no question about that if it's
definitely worked out for you and that
this the show is just phenomenal it's
just truly remarkable and it's it is as
you pointed out in our previous segment
it can be vicious and sadistic and
people seem to not be able to get enough
of that
and then there's dragons mm-hmm I think
it's it's um it's coming to its
conclusion now obviously and it's I
think it's I think it's sort of it it's
really it's changed the way TV works in
many ways it's change how how our story
moves along and and and narrative within
TV and I think what's going to be
interesting now is watching people
people's reactions to the last this
season and the last season I think
itself changes is kind of the this
season is very different in moves
from with formal pace and Season eight
that has not been shot yet is what
you're saying no okay no do you know how
this one's up I've got clue I've got my
own theory like what later I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna say no icon icon come on
no I really can't because I actually
think I'm right
and that makes it you get that makes it
even more wrong or you do not say
anything I can't I really can't I know
I'd love to it's but I just can't do you
right in a minute I'm gonna cut around
the edges in does it involve you knowing
who becomes who does sit on the Iron
Throne I'm Christopher no no you Susan
is it your ass in the iron front I can't
say okay I've gone okay what makes you
think you're so right I can't know
something you normally you know I think
I feel like I don't nothing I've been
trying to figure this out like everyone
has for four years and then I had an
epiphany the other night no I suddenly
saw it the other night I suddenly
realized what how it ends and I'm not
saying because I I'm gonna ask David
Benioff when I seem layer because I
think I figured it out will he give you
a straight answer no he never gives
anyone's playoffs does he even know do
you think my head what Dan Weiss and
David Benioff definitely know yeah they
know how this is gonna work yeah yeah
for sure I hope so I hope so
well I don't know I mean otherwise
they're brick in it as well there's a
crick in aterna what okay well is Kelvin
and so well at least we know that you're
in season eight can't say kaveri I know
nothing to see how I tried that right
yeah I'm an expert though I've been
doing this for years is that right yeah
just deny everything
I I work in sports for living so
interviewing subjects are always trying
to stonewall me yeah I know I know the
way around it every now and then but I'm
trying to get something out of you is
there a major character that we know
major character yeah from Season one
them all the way to the present deck
yeah that perishes in season seven um
very I mean is it does very no no no no
no entirely this year
no one ever loved
there any mildly boring scenes is there
anybody that comes back already buddy
that comes back anybody that comes back
yeah no no no no no one comes back no
one dies what can I tell you nothing
really
okay obviously obviously it's getting so
complex now to try and sell the show
because I don't know what though I what
what to tease you with well I mean other
than it's just Game of Thrones yeah
people die people die okay yeah shocking
things happen yeah this is huge I mean
death count wise okay like this putting
the biggest seasons and lots of nudity
yeah okay
there's dragons mother of dragons mm-hmm
who is our favorite right brockman would
you say that that's your favorite
character mother of dragons I would say
Jon Snow's my favorite case why not
outside of present somebody don't show
me up that's so wrong outside of present
company yeah bonkie okay you were um
well last one is how do you consume the
shows do you watch them on Sundays have
like a kid Harrington viewing party i
watch it on my own
what do you mean I don't know I can't
watch them with other people what do you
mean because I see I sit there in a
state of nervous tension and I only
watch them once and I was a mama in a
dark room and then I mean nervous
tension I'm whew I'm weeping and I'm
enjoying it and I'm like but I'm on my
own it's just sad it's a sad thing do
you need a hug America my dear would you
like would you like to end with a hug
yeah December the high pitch oh here we
go here we go this is great the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy